sabemos que las sucesiones aritméticas y
geométricas van avanzando de acuerdo a
cierto patrón que indica la cantidad que
se suma o se multiplica y también
sabemos que existen fórmulas para
encontrar términos muy alejados en la
serie como esta expresión que representa
una sucesión aritmética
al sustituir colocamos un uno en el
lugar de la n porque sabemos que el
primer término es a 1 así que tenemos
tres por uno más dos que nos da 5
el segundo término resulta de sustituir
la n por el 2 y tenemos que 3 por 12 62
es igual a 8
para el tercer término sustituimos el 3
en donde aparece la n de nuestra fórmula
y 3 por 3 son 9 + 2 11
así podemos obtener cualquier término
como por ejemplo el 20 de la misma
manera sustituimos la n por un 20 y
tenemos que 3 por 20 es 60 más 2 suman
62 pero como podemos comprobar que
efectivamente el 62 ocupa el lugar 20 de
nuestra sucesión si lo comprobamos
estaríamos más que seguros de que la
fórmula si funciona entonces usemos una
calculadora
como puedes ver esta sucesión aritmética
inicia con un 5 y va sumando 3 al número
anterior
así que tecleamos el 5 en la calculadora
y luego más 3
en esta operación calculamos el segundo
término a partir del primero que es 5
al teclear el símbolo de igual aparece 8
como resultado pero es muy importante
que aquí no muevas nada más a pesar de
que las calculadoras parecen aparatos o
aplicaciones muy sencillas tienen algo
muy útil y eso es una memoria a corto
plazo ya integrada que les permite
recordar cuál fue la operación anterior
entonces si tecleamos únicamente el
igual nos pondrá en la pantalla el 11
sin tener que estar tecleando + 3 cada
vez
como el 11 es el tercer término tenemos
que teclear otras 17 veces el igual para
obtener el término de lugar 20 y
rápidamente obtenemos en pantalla como
resultado el 62
así verificamos que nuestra fórmula es
correcta y con tranquilidad la podemos
usar para calcular otros términos cuando
tengas que comprobar una progresión
geométrica es el mismo procedimiento
tomemos la progresión a n es igual a 3 a
la n menos 1 el primer término es igual
a 3 a la 1 - 1 es decir 3 a la 0 y por
lo tanto es 1
para el segundo término tenemos 3 a la 2
- 1 es decir 3 a la 1 y estrés
si tomamos la misma fórmula para
calcular el término número 10
tendremos que es 3 a la 9 que es igual a
19 mil 683 verifiquemos con la
calculadora como ya nos dimos cuenta en
los primeros términos de la sucesión se
va multiplicando por tres así que
ponemos el primer término que es 1 y lo
multiplicamos por 3 y al seleccionar el
símbolo de igual estamos calculando el
segundo término que es 3 para llegar al
término 10 tendremos que presionar el
igual ocho veces seguidas y obtenemos el
resultado de 19 mil 683 verificando el
resultado obtenido por la fórmula
recuerda primero calcular el segundo
término y ya después ir presionando el
signo de igual tantas veces como se
indique en el término descontando las
dos veces con las que iniciamos nuestra
sucesión y así es como utilizamos la
calculadora para verificar resultados de
sucesiones